nous descendons dans un lieu gardé
secret par mesure de sécurité
trois étages sous terre un bout de
stations de métro un tunnel d'une
cinquantaine de mètres
on appelle ça la 69e la station secret
du métro de montréal
nous sommes dans le centre de formation
où la société de transport de montréal
entre elles des opérateurs et les
pompiers à prévenir et combattre un
incendie
il s'agit d'une réplique grandeur nature
du métro de montréal
l'opérateur billi ue doit y subir son
examen final démontrer qui sait comment
réagir si le feu prend dans le métro
des détonations dans le tunnel dans la
voiture compris le train de 0,5
vous êtes immobilisé à quel point
kilométrique de pékin 30 0 90 1 pneus
vient d'éclater et de la fumée se dégage
de la troisième voiture doivent allouer
d'évacuer vers la station quartier je
répète d'évacuation vers la station 4 6
attention tous les voyageurs le train
point est la diva cubaine avait à
l'ouverture dépens dirigez-vous vers
l'avant que vers la station quartier
la simulation reproduit les
circonstances qui ont mené au violent
incendie de 1971 le pire de l'histoire
de la société de transport le feu avait
éclaté à la station henri-bourassa
en l'absence d'une ventilation adéquate
l'épaisse fumée empêche alors les
pompiers d'approché du brasier et une
personne
l'opérateur péri dans les flammes il
faudra 30 heures pour maîtriser
l'incendié
les dégâts s'élèvent à 30 millions en
dollars d'aujourd'hui posséder
l'évacuation et rappelez moi quand ce
sera terminé
depuis la stm a complètement revu son
système de prévention des incendies en
quelques secondes un puissant système de
ventilation éloigne la fumée il permet
l'évacuation des passagers en vous
confirmez incendie à bord du train
des bornes permettent à l'opérateur de
combattre immédiatement des flammes
mais sur les pompiers sont appelés
l'opérateur sera pas tout seul longtemps
paquin mangue s'en viennent l'aider mais
on peut content que dans les premières
minutes
c'est crucial l'opérateur des tâches
précises à faire on s'entend c'est pour
quelque chose qui se passe à tous les
semaines on est dans le très peu
probable mais possible donc on forme
l'opérateur quand même à agir en
conséquence
en réel sommes jamais arrivés mais par
contre on peut toujours se replier
préparer ça ne rapporte la confiance aux
cas arriver éventuellement une
évacuation
puis on sait où on s'en fout la stm et
en amérique
l'une des rares sociétés transport à
disposer d'un tel simulateur un centre
de formation pour se préparer au pire
est évité une tragédie ici vincent
maisonneuve radio-canada m'ont rien